j'observe son aventure sur le fond elle
n'est pas inintéressante
je la trouve terriblement classique je
trouve que ça ressemble à beaucoup de
choses que nous avons connu dans le
passé dans ses recettes qui ont pu être
expérimentée par un tony blair il y a
vingt ans un garage fraudeurs il y a
vingt ans position que voulons vous leur
est appliqué aujourd'hui à la france
finalement on a droit de regarder ce que
dit emmanuel macron je ne trouve pas ça
inintéressant je trouve tout cela
simplement vieux il ya quelque chose qui
est confus dans la candidature
d'emmanuel macron et pourtant je lui
accorde toute la sympathie à titre
personnel parce que j'ai travaillé avec
lui je le connais je ne comprends pas
comment on peut aller au puy du fou chez
monsieur philippe de villiers faire son
éloge ensuite prendre le train allait à
nevers faire l'éloge de françois
mitterrand puis reprendre le train
allait à shannon h et valéry giscard
d'estaing faire l'éloge du président
giscard d'estaing recevoir entre deux
voyages et escales le soutien de jean
pierre raffarin et les critiques de
gérard larcher
comme disait quelqu'un quand c'est flou
il y à un loup un plat quand on n'a pas
peur de poutine et qu'on n'a pas peur de
trump à ce que la france faut qu'elle se
reprenne un peu rien reprenez vous
arrivez ne nous avez pas peur on l'a
connu on l'a connu secrétaire général
adjoint de l'elysée était charmant la
gauche se rassemblera il cherche à faire
croire que c'est pas la gauche qui l'a
nommé à pas de chance il était ministre
de hollande et je pense aussi de manuel
valls le croit et puis à un moment il va
sortir de l'ambiguïté
ça peut être à son détriment mais sa
grande famille l'accueillera c'est à
vous savez l'enfant prodige il est parti
et reviendra je vous lis pas à vous mais
ça suffit
parce que d'une certaine manière et nous
le constatons encore au coude
au cours de ces dernières heures il y a
les forces politiques force de presse et
fort qu'ils veulent empêcher que cette
primaire se passe dans de bonnes
conditions moi je rends compte des
françaises et des français comme nous
tous et nous tôt je pense et qui en
effet me disent tu peux pas qu'ils
hésitent qu'ils hésitent et qu'ils
peuvent être tentés par la candidature
d'emmanuel macron parce qu'il y a un
besoin de renouveau
et moi mon objectif politique après la
primaire qu'il faut réussir plus il y
aura de votants mieux ce sera c'est qu'
il y ait un rassemblement pour qu'il n'y
ait pas un deuxième tour de l'élection
présidentielle entre françois fillon et
marine